i'm honored and pleased to be the 2020
recipient of the napd
lifetime achievement award
it's special to be recognized by one's
peers
also i want to thank the members of the
selection committee for choosing me
and for the people who wrote
letters of recommendation
supporting my nomination
it's very much appreciated thank you
i don't have time to acknowledge and
individually all the people who have
contributed to the level of success that
i've had
but i do want to mention
my parents and other members of the
community where i grew up for their
support of education and me personally
also
warren goblin my major professor at
uw-madison who by the way turned 100
this past spring
and other mentors there
i was also fortunate to
be able to work with and to be the major
professor for
graduate students and post-docs that i
thoroughly enjoyed
you've done very good done very well
after
finishing your degrees and i'm very
proud of the accomplishments that you've
made
i chose to talk to talk on the topic of
perspectives of managing
change this should ring a bell with
those of us in
napb because indeed there's been a lot
of change just for the
meetings these last two years going from
in-person to virtual
i think the organizing committees have
done a really good job of doing that so
thank you very much
yes these times are changing
and
each time there's a change we have to
ask the question should i hang on to the
old or should i grab onto the new
change comes at us from all directions
when i first started working with
seminus vegetable seeds
i came home one evening and remarked to
mary that this job is a
director of worldwide breeding i think
it's going to be quite good and and fun
when things settle down a bit but guess
what they never really did settle down
there was always change going on i
should have expected this
but i didn't and so we've able to cope
with this
change comes from different directions
some is expected and some not
unexpected or unplanned
some is incremental and some is abrupt
some is widespread such as the global
climate change we're experiencing
sometimes we can initiate change
ourselves and that can be very positive
it's really this ongoing change that
creates much of the dynamic nature of
plant breeding but we have to be aware
of change in order to influence the
outcomes to our advantage
we also have to be able to cope with
change
be a person who brings
solutions not problems to the
organization keep an open mind put
yourself in other people's shoes don't
rush to judgment
practice continuing education use cross
training for yourself
for members of your team to keep you
updated to meet these challenges
when change comes and sometimes it does
and it's threatening it can be
overpowering
don't hesitate to help to seek help from
others and sometimes professionals
well each time we have these changes
that we encounter we have the
opportunity to either reject or delay or
to accept
either way we do it there's
opportunities for risk and reward life's
pretty much about risk and reward if we
miss opportunities sometimes that's a
big miss sometimes it's not so bad
because things turn out all right if we
accept we have to be ready to invest in
new time people and resources
should i hang on to the old or grab on
to do
that can be a difficult question in
every case
i've listed here
the personal changes that
i've encountered during my career as
plant breeding starting with the
education that i received
first from the university of nebraska
then
my graduate work at uw-madison and then
a post-doc at the university of
minnesota
my first job was at uw-madison where i
joined the faculty of the horticulture
department
working on vegetable crop research and
breeding
in teaching and
education after 22 years there i had the
opportunity to move to uc davis where i
joined the faculty of the pomology
department
working on fruit crops that was a big
change not only did we have to move from
the midwest to california but i was
working on perennial
crops rather than the seed propagated
annuals
it was quite different
i spent a decade there and then had the
opportunity to move to
the private sector with feminist
vegetable seeds
again working on vegetable crops but
quite different being in r d management
rather than research directly
after a dozen years there i decided to
retire and spent the rest of the time
since then as an independent consultant
each time i had decisions to make
individually along with members of my
family and others
each time we could either grab on to the
new challenge or not i did and i think
it turned out pretty well
there were other changes occurring
in plant breeding during my career
changes to the profession itself
when i began we were using primarily
phenotypic selection and quantitative
breeding
and focused a lot on progeny selection
and combining ability
and then the era of dna informed
breeding was ushered in when dna
sequencing and replication became
rather routine
and now we've integrated all of these
things we've added to the things that we
had with new ideas new technology new
science we're in the age of integrated
breeding
sometimes it was the science and
technology and the devices that drove
those changes other times there was
change that we had to innovate and
create new things in those areas
we're now in the era entering genome
editing and artificial intelligence
using big data sets and cloud computing
and i dare say there will probably be as
much change over the next 50 years as
there has been in the past
i want to spend a few uh some time here
with a few of the examples of change
that have occurred to me and
how i've addressed these changes
the first one that i recall was a big
biological change that occurred after i
just got back from nigeria in the early
part of my uh career at uw-madison
this was the
uh southern north southern corn leaf
blight epidemic of 1771.
it occurred very abruptly
and it was one of the most damaging and
costly outbreaks in agriculture in north
america
it was due to a confluence of an over
reliance on the texas or the t male
sterile cytoplasm
for the production of inver female
inbred lines for
seed production
and there was a mutant race of the
insight and pathogen that had been
rather dormant had been around that
hadn't been of much consequence for a
number of years
and it became very prevalent and caused
this outbreak
along with genetic uniformity
this raised the red flag about genetic
vulnerability from over the amount from
an overt amount of plant uniformity we
hadn't really talked about that much in
the past but it indeed became something
that we needed to consider
there were direct and associated changes
of this epidemic
to the seed corn industry where they had
to change from the use of the t
cytoplasmic male sterile parent seed
parents
began again de-tasseling the seed
parrots such as they'd done in the old
days
until they found new sources of
resistance which is now being used
there was some effects on other crops as
well because we looked at a lot of the
crops and found that they were in fact
genetically vulnerable there was too
much genetic uniformity
this led to the recommendations of
broadening the genetic base
but we found that there was in many
cases insufficient germplasm and
technology that we had at our disposable
at disposal in order to address these
issues
overall there was a good outcome of that
however because there was more there
were more resources that were allocated
for the collection
and the use of germplasm
and there were new programs created the
first time we really talked about
germplasm enhancement or pre-breeding
and these became rather common and
they're in use today
it also impacted my bean braiding
program
both the dry bean and the snap bean of
the garden bean cultivars had a very
narrow genetic base
they're having difficult time producing
new cultivars that were higher yielding
and better in the culinary aspects
more diverse germplasm was needed
in order to use that we'd be making wide
crosses and pedigree selection and
recurrent selection were of limited
value for this particular crop so a new
approach was needed
this led me to formulate the idea of the
inbred backross method which i published
in an article in hort science in 1981.
i'm shown here the stick diagram of the
process and the procedures
used in developing
inbred backross lines for replicated
trials and testing
well we know from experience that when
both parents are superior or equal and
relatively equal in genetic superiority
pedigree selection is preferred and it's
quite good been used for a long time
when one parent superior and one is
poorly adapted
one or more back crosses increases the
probability of recovering recombinants
that are better than the best parent so
we need that for selection in the inbred
back cross populations and indeed that's
better than pedigree selection in these
cases
i want to talk about a couple of other
uh
examples here
when i was the director of breeding at
seminas
the first occurred when our director of
st seed foundation seed stock and
foundation seeds became ill after a trip
abroad
he was severely ill and was out of work
for
six to nine months
but the department functioned pretty
well because they had undergone a lot of
cross-training and a lot of exposure to
each member of the
the department into the activities of
other members
so that went pretty well and they really
didn't miss a beat until he came back
in good health and could continue
the other situation in crisis management
occurred when
one of the associate directors of
worldwide breeding and a key breeder in
his group left rather unexpectedly
they turned in their letters of
recommendation on a monday morning just
as we were getting ready for a research
meeting
we weren't very pr well prepared for
that but we hadn't anticipated that and
we didn't know that was coming
and we didn't have anybody prepared to
step in on that it took a while to fill
these positions so
this led me to think in terms of how
could we make some changes and that led
to the concept of transition planning
what's transition planning do well it
considers the changes that we know will
occur but we don't know when or which
they'll be
it answers the question of who does what
when somebody's unable to do their work
because of illness or absence
and it also provides an opportunity for
each person to see what the other does
to find out what he or she does
put yourself in that person's shoes
if we do this in a good way and we can
standardize this there's some good
outcomes
there are many people or several people
in the department that understand can
handle each job of that team
it prepares the employees for other
responsibilities and opportunities
they may not have been aware of that
they had some talent for
and most of all it works pretty well for
both planned and unplanned changes
well we're in the midst of
at least three major changes that are
affecting plant breeding and i could
list many more if time allowed
we have the copa covet 19 global
pandemic that we're hopefully
on the way out of
in the midst of global climate change
which
we don't know for sure how long that's
going to last in the severity but we
know it's increasing
we're also from the standpoint of our
profession we're undergoing a change in
definition in the demographics
of the plant breeding profession in
other words who are the professional
plant breeders that are being trained
and moving into positions of
leadership
and our challenge is how to respond to
and manage amid these changes
well indeed the
two global changes are ongoing are
similar in some ways
but they're quite different in other
ways that i've listed here
the important thing to recognize is that
the plant breeding science and
technology and the phase changes that i
talked about
these weren't the drivers and aren't the
drivers of these change the change is
coming about from external factors
and we as plant breeders are being asked
to respond to this in the best way we
can to help mitigate the changes that
are occurring
we have to innovate and to adapt to
these
and hopefully i believe we can do that
with the
people and the tools and the technology
that we have
i think transition planning will help
especially in the case of
person power to meet these challenges
well i did i said that there were
changes in the profession itself and the
definition of demographics
plant breeding is indeed evolving from
what used to be solely cultivar breeding
it now includes many other activities
that i've mentioned here
such as germplasm enhancement and
pre-breeding we need to include all the
people that are contributing as breeders
a little bit different categories but
nevertheless they're essential and
should be recognized as breeders
plant breeding is changing from a white
male-dominated profession
beginning in the late 70s more women
were being admitted into graduate
programs and then moving into the
professional ranks of breeders
we're seriously underrepresented by the
minorities this is increasing slowly
and in each case we need more urgency to
meet the greater need for diversity
among the people in plant breeding
i would say that a goal is for all who
aspire to be breeders should be
encouraged and have equal opportunities
to achieve their goal i'll leave you
with a question i think you'll find
interesting when you see some of the
answers
that is
who was the first woman plant breeder in
your company your college or experiment
station when was she hired
i've done a little bit of work on this
and i found some things about people i
didn't really know about they made great
contributions and should be recognized
i'll just summarize in the following way
each of you are going to experience
change of all kinds it's going to come
at you in all directions
there's going to be direct and
collateral effects from these changes
sometimes there's a cascade of events
that give you some outcomes that you
hadn't expected
we need to learn both from the successes
and the crises that we face
to make new approaches for expected and
unexpected change
we need to embrace and support changes
to plant breeding profession and expand
the definition
of plant breeding and the people who are
being trained and educated moving into
positions of
of authority and direction
most of all enjoy your plant breeding
career as much as i have thank you very
much